wir essen plastik immer mehr davon
sammelt sich in den weltmeeren und
fische fressen es die wir dann wiederum
essen wie unsere nahrungskette so
langsam verseucht wird jetzt den krieg
zum science fiction
schlechte nachrichten für alle die gerne
mal was essen das plastik ist angekommen
und zwar an unserer nahrungskette und
jetzt wissen wir auch wie viel es ist
und das sind erschreckende zahlen die
neueste studie schlägt jetzt alarm laut
dem fünfjahres institut schwimmen in den
weltmeeren 269.000 tonnen plastikmüll
das sind fast 40.000 müllwagen ladung
das ist nur der müll der oben schwimmt
das ist nicht nur eine ziemlich schlimme
sauerei sondern auch üble verseuchung
der umwelt viele denken bei plastikmüll
an hässliche tüten flasche styropor
folien und so weiter dass es unschöne
und auch daran sterben tiere die sich
darin verfangen und qualvoll verhungern
und oder ersticken aber das ist nur die
spitze des eisbergs
das team um den forscher marcus ericsson
hat um die müllmenge genauer zu
bestimmen die daten aus 24
untersuchungen mit 1500 sammlungen und
beobachtungen zusammen getragen und ist
so auf diese hohe menge gekommen dabei
ist die anzahl der tonnen noch nicht mal
so hoch wenn man die zahl der
plastikteilchen hört es sind fünf
millionen teilchen sprich 5000
milliarden plastikteilchen die in
unseren ozean schwimmen eine absolut
erschreckende zahl viel schlimmer ist
aber das was die forscher nicht gefunden
haben
die menge der plastikteile mit der größe
eines sandkorn soir 100 mal geringer als
vermutet
und das ist ein ganz schlechtes zeichen
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten die teilchen
gelangen in tiefere wasserschichten oder
und das ist ein wirkliches
horrorszenario werden in riesigen mengen
von fischen gegessen
die folgen wären fatal die studien die
sich mit den auswirkungen von plastik
auf fische befassen verheißen nichts
gutes das problem ist das mit dem
plastik giftstoffe in die fische
gelangen die sie ansonsten nicht in
diesem maße aufnehmen würden nicht nur
die während der produktion in den
kunststoff gelangten chemikalien sind
dabei schädlich sondern auch chemikalien
die die plastikteilchen aus dem wasser
aufnehmen
die chemikalien reichern sich dann in
den fischen an und vergiften sie das hat
eine studie der university of california
in davis ergeben dort wurden fische mit
plastik haltiger nahrung gefüttert und
genau diese anreicherung geschah dann
wenn jetzt also die ganzen micro
plastikteilchen verschwunden sind
dann ist eben ein sehr plausibles
szenario dass sie in großem maße in
unserer nahrung landen und wenn man sich
jetzt untersuchungen dazu ansieht dann
wird genau das bestätigt fisch ist heute
immer mehr mit schadstoffen belastet das
schlimme ist dass es zuchtfische
besonders betrifft sie werden mit
fischmehl gefüttert
alles klar es ist wirklich eine
katastrophe diese alles vergiften und
wir es dann auch mit sowas wie plastik
noch verstärken
die folgen sind mehr krebserkrankungen
weniger spermien und vieles mehr
eine signifikante schädigung unserer
gesundheit doch es gibt einen lichtblick
bojan slut ist 20 jahre alt und hat
einen kühnen traum er will die weltmeere
vom plastik befreien
zwei millionen euro hat er für versuche
gesammelt um seine idee in die tat
umzusetzen
er wird fangarme in den weltmeeren
montieren die den ganzen müll einsammeln
zusammen soll das projekt sechs
milliarden euro kosten eigentlich ein
klacks
hoffen wir mal dass er das projekt in
die tat umsetzen kann für unsere
gesundheit um gesundheit geht es auch in
diesem video clip spontan gehalt das ist
wirklich eine irre geschichte aus der
mayo klinik in den usa hier klicken für
das video täglich news aus der
wissenschaft gibt es in der app und im
blog dass es hier allerdings auch in der
video beschreibung und was meint ihr was
sollen wir gegen diese schlimme
umweltverschmutzung tun sollen wir
überhaupt noch plastiktüten verwenden
diskutiert es mit mir in den kommentaren
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran